I've got to address what is really a
horrible issue that's surfaced with
patreon over the last five days and it's
killing us I have no other way to say it
I'm not going to sugarcoat it it is
killing us for people who don't know
patreon is a platform on which we
launched in early April of 2017 in
response to YouTube D monetization when
you go to patreon.com/scishow you see
that we have at this point over two
thousand patrons who pledge anywhere
from $1 all the way up to no upper limit
per month and that is in support of the
program it's one of the bigger funding
sources of the program now that we've
grown this over the last seven or eight
months the problem is that at November's
end we had nearly 2,200 patreon
contributors and patreon a few days ago
restructured how their fees work the way
it worked before this restructuring is
that people would make a contribution to
patreon and patreon would take a piece
of that that's their fee for running the
platform and then there would also be
payment processing fees and we would end
up as the creators with anywhere between
92 and 96 or so percent of each person's
pledge depending on a number of factors
how are they funding their pledge what's
the size of their pledge etc so a few
days ago patreon community communicated
to everybody to creators and to patrons
alike that they've restructured their
fees the good news of the restructuring
was that we as the creators would end up
getting 95% of all contributions period
there wouldn't be this variability where
we might end up with less or maybe a
little more we would end up with 95
cents from every dollar that's pledged
the part that a lot of our patrons
didn't like is that patreon restructured
so that there would be an addition of
more of a fee to some pledges that the
patron would pay for so some of that fee
was shifted from the creator us to the
patron you and it was not commune
in a good way in reality we're talking
for most pledges of a tiny statistical
change but people understandably didn't
like it this is a major mistake that
patreon made and I've been in touch with
them and they've told me we recognized
that we did not communicate this in a
good way we recognize that you're
hurting and the problem is as you can
see when you look at patreon.com slash
david pakman show is that it's hurting
us a lot we have lost about a hundred
and fifty patrons and people are
contacting me saying David I can no
longer support you on patreon after the
decision that they made so I want to say
a few things about this because it's
really affecting us and I don't want
this to further drag us down number one
this is a small change for most pledges
okay if you want to be supporting us big
picture over the course of a year this
is not changing by too much anything
okay it was communicated poorly it may
not be the best policy but big picture
for most pledges it's not a big
difference so that's that's number one
and I would encourage you to consider
Reap Legend on patreon because we really
do increasingly depend on that money
okay but number two if you're going to
cancel from patreon I totally respect
your decision but please please please
don't punish us and come over to
membership and recreate your support on
our website okay if you do choose to
move your patreon pledge over to
membership we control that platform a
hundred percent there's no platform fee
all we pay in fees is 30 cents plus 2.9
percent that's that's exactly what we
pay and we keep everything else from the
pledges from the membership payments
that come in so I get it right I respect
that you as an activist might say I want
to communicate to patreon that they are
wrong I'm cutting my pledge so that
patreon doesn't get a piece of it
anymore that's fine but I would
encourage you to go over to david
pakman.com slash membership and move
your support there because I believe
that most of you maybe some of you do
want to punish us but most of you don't
want to punish the David Pakman show and
if you were doing just a couple of bucks
on patreon and you don't want to do the
$6 a month membership which is the
cheapest one on our website no problem
there's a coupon code which is I voted 7
tene which will drop your monthly cost
to just three dollars and sixty cents
per month which is really quite
reasonable you'll get a lot of great
membership perks and and lastly you can
also get a free twenty eighteen calendar
the calendar looks fantastic you can go
to david pakman.com slash calendar 18
you can get the calendar for free with a
new yearly membership can't use the
coupon code though if you pay full price
for a yearly you can get a free calendar
or you can also get just the calendar
all right and the calendar looks really
really great this year but so so bottom
line I understand the frustration with
patreon I think that this was a
boneheaded PR move by them even if
financially it's not a big change for
for really anybody but please don't
punish us and consider bringing your
support over to membership so that we
can continue doing everything that we're
doing and by the way I've been talking
about how when we get to twenty two
hundred and fifty patreon contributors
we're going to do a multi-part critical
thinking miniseries for you it is
looking really good already I saw the
sort of introductory animation that is
going to be part of that miniseries and
also we're finishing up the bullet
points and talking the topics for that
series it's going to be really really
good and we still want to do that okay
so please continue supporting us because
it really is allowing us to push back
against YouTube's D monetization and do
a lot of really great new content for
you so that's that's the story there for
everybody who's been emailing me about
it